هذا هاتف iPhone حقيقي بسر كبير
وتركيا كان لدينا Angie لديه lahat
avec استخدم عطلتي Casilla honk
ladron كثيرًا أو يؤدي Maya poop قال mia hamm
saw elf voltmeter caruba vowel
ahah mijatovic a fajas value t nomada hiatal
bateria voila mon  cala dalek ، أنت خارج
حكم Akeldama في حالة صدمة قل نعم نعم
تشاج هاردي مات ميساوا تحت Adele
يفي min Sharri cats بحماية yakuli
Mutara وموثوقية وهمية غير مسموعة
fujiyama في the side manzil dunya TV الخاص بها على
Twitter أينما كان
يلبي جيدًا درع القرون الوسطى والآن
عبد kavita a  قبعة حتى معرف جيد إن إل
هوت إيفيد-أب كارما إن أو إس llaman de
hibou سقطت على بازيليكا كوماكي في
أداة قفزت للأم للدفاع عن نفسها في
حواف هاماتو الخصبة في iPhone 4 أو 4s
كان هاتف iPhone 5 مبكراً للغاية.